american actor alec baldwin says he is
shocked and saddened after fatally
shooting a crew member on a film set in
a tweet he described the incident as a
tragic accident the actor discharged a
gun being used as a prop director of
photography helena hutchins seen here a
few days ago while filming the western
rust died of her injuries the movie's
director joel souza was also hit but
he's now been released from hospital
police have interviewed mr baldwin and
are investigating whether the bullet was
a blank or a live round they say no
charges have been filed
well dw culture reporter scott
roxborough is following this story
welcome scott tell us more about alec
baldwin's tweet
uh yes i mean uh you uh uh read the
portion of it there that he said he was
uh shocked and heartbroken
in regards this instant which happened
uh in new mexico uh during the
production of a film that he is both
starring in and is producing a western
uh called rust uh and uh the incident uh
apparently occurred um during normal
stave affairs
on production where uh baldwin was using
a prop gun which is usually incredibly
safe uh uh device incredibly well
controlled on a film set um and uh it
discharged um and uh the uh um
result was the death of the director of
photography uh um and uh injury to uh
the director of the movie the director
uh has since been released uh from um
from hospital um and is no longer in
danger but of course um uh ms hutchinson
as you mentioned um was was fatally
injured uh by uh by the incident and uh
baldwin um um said in his tweet uh and
that's been of course confirmed by the
santa fe police in new mexico that he
has been cooperating with the
investigation that immediately went to
the police um uh for for questioning and
has been released and has not been
charged the police so far have not
issued any arrests and not charged
anyone in regards to this incident and
are still investigating to try and find
out what actually took place right so it
seems amazing that this has actually
happened because one would expect there
to be strict controls on the way that
guns are used on set
yes and there and there are i mean uh
prop guns uh are very common uh in in
american film and television production
um and they're incredibly strictly
controlled there's usually an armor or a
person who controls the munitions uh uh
on on set uh there are very very strict
protocols that are followed uh when
using uh these these these prop guns
because although they are props they are
can be effective weapons um and
typically there would never be a live
ammunition in in in these prop guns um
and they will be very very strictly
controlled so the fact that uh this um
this tragedy occurred um is is really
quite baffling um the um the instance
faith of fatalities involving prop guns
are are so few as to be really counted
on one hand um a very famous case of
course with um brendan lee the son of
bruce lee uh who was killed in the 90s
um in an incident um on on on a film
where um he a prop gun was used that had
a projectile in the barrel which
shouldn't have happened and uh he was
fatally shot by that but incidents like
this are so uncommon to be um as i said
almost inconceivable
and how are people reacting to this news
uh well i mean as with al baldwin it's
shock and and disbelief uh uh there's
been um uh uh
that sort of uh sentiment you've seen
across hollywood uh uh today um the um
main union for behind-the-scenes workers
uh issued a statement just recently um
saying um how saddened uh they were um
and calling for for renewed vigilance
when it comes to safety uh on set this
is something that uh hollywood has
always
put a focus on and most recently because
of the covid uh pandemic safety on set
has become even more important um so
that makes of course this instant um all
the more surprising and and all the more
shocking and and uh has filming uh
closed down then
uh filming on this film yes they've they
shut down for an indefinite period while
the police investigates of course what
happened um and also while um the uh
workers on set are are treated for uh
for the trauma uh um uh uh of the
involving in the incident and the
production team has said that they are
providing counseling for all members of
of the uh cast and crew on the set and
of course it's very unclear when and if
uh production will resume
thank you so much for that dw culture
reporter scott roxborough
you